- Please tell me that Dan
has styled you before,
and for TikTok, please.
(Kelly laughing)
- No, he, he, he,
not for TikTok.
- Not for TikTok,
what was it for?
- He did style me once,
a few years ago for some opening,
premiere, you know,
one of the things.
- He's got great taste.
- And he did dress me.
But, you know, (coughs)
I was
going out of town,
I was waiting for the car
to take me to the airport.
And I, you know, I used
to put on a shirt and tie
and jacket, you know,
jeans, that kind of thing.
But I was into that.
He walks out one day, he was four,
and he looks at me standing,
waiting for the car.
And he's looking at me and I
said, "What is it, Daniel?"
He said,
"From here up,
great."
- (laughing)
- "From here down, gross."
- Gross.
(audience laughing)
- I said, "You don't like
the jeans with the thing?"
- (Gina laughing)
- He was four.
(audience laughing)
- My-
- And he has the greatest
sense of style now.
- [Kelly] He does.
He does.
- Yes, he's a fashion icon.
- Amazing.
- My six and eight year
old will call, literally,
we're going to dinner,
my friend is in the building
hearing this right now,
and we are about ready to
go and my son looked at me,
he's six.
(audience laughing)
And he looked at me and he goes,
"So, are you gonna go get ready?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Oh.
- I was like,
- [Gina] (laughing)
- "Sorry, but I look
really good right now."
I was like, "What?"
- [Gina] (laughing)
- I was like, I looked
really cute, Nirvana grunge,
I thought I was pulling it off.
- (chuckles)
- And, like,
I had literally come straight from work.
And then my daughter
comes around the corner,
not kidding, didn't even hear Remi say it,
and River comes around the
corner and she was like,
"What, are you going like that?"
And I was like, "What the
heck is wrong with me?"
(audience and Eugene laughing)
All my friends were there.
I went just like that,
I'll have you know.
- [Gina] Good, good.
- You did not bully me into changing.
- Yes, they're brutal,
- [Kelly] (chuckles)
- they are brutal.
- Look, I'm gonna hold onto
it though, at least they're
looking at me paying attention.